encore une semaine de révisions et jeudi
prochain ce sera le début du
baccalauréat avec les épreuves de
philosophie et si les thèmes changent la
fraude s'adapte aussi mais attention les
sanctions peuvent être lourdes stéphanie
déjà mélissa monteiro
ce pourrait être n'importe quel lycée et
n'importe quel élève
que celui qui n'a jamais triché lève la
main le contrôle aux alentours autour de
la cartouche on referme l'antisèche le
procédé est sans doute aussi vieux que
l'école des générations d'élèves ont
transgresser l'interdît de la triche
dans les cours de récréation ce n'est
pas un tabou mais presque un jeu doublé
du frisson de ne pas se faire prendre et
les colliers d'aujourd'hui c'est mettre
à profit les nouvelles technologies
comme le net
cité par exemple ses bâtons de colle et
on marque ce qu'on veut tuer après cela
il suffit d'imprimer les étiquettes de
truquer une des meilleures astuces du
web tricheurs quelques clics et vous
choisissez la bonne marque cole tipp ex
il suffit ensuite de taper les formules
à ne pas oublier un dernier clic et les
ti cats est prêt à être imprimé et
recoller ici par exemple sur une
bouteille d'eau ces sites tout ou partie
dédiée à la triche se multiplient
derrière je casio points comme jérôme un
tout jeune homme de 17 ans sa spécialité
le remplissage des mémoires des
calculatrices les plus utilisés par les
lycéens n'a pas besoin de taper c'est
déjà tout fait en dix minutes on peut
avoir un cours de math complète sans
maîtrise toute une année toute une année
la calculatrice est admise dans la
plupart des épreuves scientifiques du
bac
sauf si elle permet de communiquer mais
sur le contenu des mémoires l'éducation
nationale ferme les yeux quand même
comprendre le sujet juste avec le court
ne maîtrise pas on pourra difficilement
arriver à faire quelque chose environ
500 mille candidats passent leur bac
chaque année l'an dernier seuls 150
d'entre eux ont fait l'objet d'une
procédure pour fraude ou tentative de
fraude
mais devant les commissions
disciplinaires il est alors difficile de
se justifier et les sanctions sont
parfois très lourdes comme en témoigne
claude timsit qui présidait la
commission de l'académie de versailles
toute fraude au baccalauréat peut être
lourdement sanctionnés si vous voulez la
liste des sanctions peut aller jusqu'à
l'interdiction définitive de passer un
examen
mieux vaut donc ne pas tricher et même
se mettre à l'abri doit tout soupçon en
laissant par exemple son téléphone
portable à la maison
la réussite au bac en sera plus sûr est
bien meilleure
[Musique]